you are watching ColdFusion TV hi
welcome to another ColdFusion video so
this is it an affordable electric car
for the masses that can outperform your
standard petrol car at the same price
for many decades this has just been a
pipe dream because the technology was
not yet good enough or cheap enough to
make it a reality there were also some
other reasons but we're not going to go
into that right now anyway at a frenzied
event in California Tesla has just
unveiled their endgame car the model 3
which could be the very beginning of the
mainstream electric car
so what's all the fuss about is this car
actually any good and what is the wider
picture here for Tesla in this video
we'll take a look and find out firstly
let's take a look at some aspects of the
model 3 to start off the model 3 will be
an incredibly safe car it has a
five-star safety rating for various
reasons but one of the major ones is
that versus a normal car there's an
extremely large crumple zone at the
front instead of a giant steel engine
hurtling towards you in the event of an
accident the model 3 will do 0 to 60
miles an hour or about 100 kilometers an
hour in less than six seconds and that's
the slowest model there's versions that
will go much faster than that you're
going to get 215 miles or 346 kilometers
per charge and all Tesla Model 3 s will
come with the super charging as standard
Elon Musk the CEO of Tesla states that
there's now 3600 charges worldwide but
at the end of the year they'll be
doubling the number of charges as for
practicality the car can comfortably fit
five adults and has plenty of space for
extra storage seeing as there's no
engine under the bonnet all model threes
will come standard with autopilot a
self-driving feature that can steer
break and even park or drive to you when
you're not in the car
I've made a separate video on how
autopilot works and it's pretty cool so
if you want to know more information
about that hit the annotation or click
on the corresponding link below so what
about that price
well the Tesla Model 3 is set to start
at 35,000 US dollars Tesla states that
even with no extras you're not going to
be able to find a better car at $35,000
alright so seen a little bit about some
of the features of the car but what
about the wider picture what does this
mean for Tesla well the model 3 is the
next step in the company's evolution
from a high-end luxury electric car
maker to a manufacturer of an affordable
product for mainstream car owners the
move is very bold and presents a major
risk for Tesla to create a car that it
can sell so cheaply Tesla needed to make
some big risk
decisions the company is building a
massive multi-billion dollar factory in
Nevada that all mass produce batteries
to help make them and the cars that they
power cheaper musk has said a Tesla
couldn't make the model 3 without the
battery factory the company wants to
churn out enough batteries at the
facility to make half a million electric
cars annually the aim of the Giga
Factory is to reduce the cost of
batteries by 30 percent using various
techniques such as large-scale
manufacturing to leverage an economy of
scale and innovative supply chain for
sourcing and new chemistry techniques
Asian giants like Panasonic have been
investing heavily in increasing supply
so really the model 3 is a bit of a
make-or-break moment for Tesla if the
aspects that the company is bet on do
indeed go the right way we could be
seeing a massive shift in the auto
industry in the coming decade
expectations are already high so high
that 115,000 cars have already been
ordered in just 24 hours but why exactly
is this for some fun let's quantify this
if we think about things little deeper
will quickly begin to see why so many
people bought the car the value equation
otherwise known as consumer perceived
value is the ratio of benefits to cost
so quickly the benefits here are as
follows
never having to fill petrol again
superior safety handling and
acceleration intrinsically due to
advantages of an electric design and
also an arguably good-looking car and
the costs thirty-five thousand US
dollars and perhaps the inconvenience of
charging but that's set to go away with
the increase of super charges some
people out there would probably also
miss the raw sound of a petrol
combustion engine but the thing is a
completely silent car might actually be
a positive point for some people so
really just quantifiably speaking the
car is literally great value so there it
is the first mass-market electric car
that is
why fully under powered it's really an
amazing time to be witnessing all of
this a wish Tesla the best and I really
hope that this is the beginning of a
revolution that takes us off our
addiction to fossil fuels well that's
the end of the video thanks for watching
guys and one thing if you want to really
see who made the electric car possible
in the first place
check out my documentary on Nikola Tesla
it's one of my best pieces of work and a
link to it will be available right after
this and lastly I just wanted to say a
big thank you to you all and a special
thank you to all of you on patreon it
helps the channel out this has been to
gogo you've been watching cold fusion
don't forget to give this video a thumbs
up if you liked it and feel free to
share it Cheers
have a good one cold fusion if you
thinking
you
my culture we were